if i were a struggling gym owner right
now
first thing i would do is i would get a
cash flow injection and so what i would
do is probably pre-sell five to ten
people for a year because then i could
get probably you know five to ten
thousand dollars of cash up front with
that money i would probably go straight
to paid ads but if i didn't do that i
would start with organic outreach
because you can join your local groups
and you can friend request those people
message them bring them to a phone call
and hey you know i'm a gym owner in xyz
area right across the street from you
you know do you or do you know anyone
who might be interested
in you know getting in shape or running
some crazy promotions right now right so
i'm not asking you i'm asking if you
know anybody so all of a sudden i'm not
really spamming you i'm just asking for
help which is a little bit different
that's 100 free it just takes effort
from that 140 who respond we get 30 of
those people on the phone so you get you
know 42 people on the phone from the 140
and of the 42 you say you close one out
of three and so you close 15 people that
kind of funnel would take a full month
right that's a full month of work
probably about one to two hours a day of
just responding to messages and whatnot
it's a four-letter word which is work a
lot of people don't want to do that